The text of John Wick is obsessed with rules
and consequences. But there are also a set of
creative guidelines and standards behind the
scenes that have helped set the series apart
from other action films. These rules explain why
audiences are so captivated by what is essentially
a simple urban fairytale.
In the world of John Wick, those who serve under
the High Table, from assassins to arms dealers to
bartenders, provide goods and services in
exchange for specially minted gold coins.
Over the course of the series, John Wick trades
coins for weapons, medical care, lodging, drinks,
and favors. But trying to determine the monetary
value of a High Table coin is futile. Coins are
not about wealth, they're about respect. In the
words of Berrada, who oversees minting the coins,
and was introduced in Chapter 3...
"This coin of course does not represent
monetary value. It represents
the commerce of relationships."
Astute viewers will note that when offered, no
one in the series has yet turned down a coin,
or refused to perform a favor for another
member of their society in exchange for one.
In a behind-the-scenes featurette, John
Wick producer and co-director David Leitch
refers to coins as tokens of membership.
Each of the first three films introduces
a talisman of sorts that defines
how that film approaches the world
Under the Table. In the first film, the
gold coins represent access, the audience's
invitation to the secret underworld.
In John Wick: Chapter 2, a second talisman is
introduced: The marker. Markers are golden tokens
which flip open like a pocket watch to reveal
a bisected silver plate inside. These plates
serve as a record of debt. When one person Under
the Table asks a significant favor of another,
the one granting the favor has the right
to demand anything in return, at any time.
The obliged party leaves a bloody thumbprint on
one side of the silver plate. The one granting
the favor keeps the marker, and presents it to the
other party when the time has come to call in the
debt. Only once the favor is complete does the
bearer leave their own bloody thumbprint inside
the marker. The High Table also keeps a record
of markers to ensure the legitimacy of all debts.
Someone holding your marker is a serious,
unbreakable commitment. Even among a society of
assassins, you are not permitted to kill someone
who holds your marker, nor may you refuse to honor
it. In Chapter Two, John initially refuses Santino
D'Antonio's marker, and Santino burns down John's
house in response, an action that holds up as
entirely justified Under the Table. In Chapter 3,
Sofia Al-Azwar honors John's marker even after
John is declared excommunicado by the High Table.
Markers are the talisman of obligation. His marker
with D’Antonio tethers John to the world of blood
and guns whether he likes it or not.
When the first John Wick begins, John is five
years retired from his life as the Baba Yaga,
an assassin so legendary that he is feared even
by those he serves. But he's only days separated
from the death of his wife, Helen, the person
for whom he left the business. His leave from
the service of Russian mob boss Viggo Tarasof
was not easily won. John earned his retirement
after the completion of an often invoked but
vaguely described "impossible" task. It is
implied throughout the series that escaping the
assassin's life alive is essentially unheard of.
Fate steps in to draw John back into the
underworld after Helen dies an untimely but
natural death. Viggo credits Helen's death to
divine retribution for John's life as an assassin.
John, who fears damnation himself, may
also believe that God is denying him rest,
though he pursues it nevertheless.
It’s appropriate then that the third
and final talisman, introduced in Chapter 3, is
John's "ticket." This important relic is a Russian
Orthodox cross and rosary that he returns to the
Director, the woman who presumably raised him,
after his excommunication. The ticket grants him a
swift and secret exit out of New York, where he's
beset on all sides by assassins looking to turn
in his head for $15 million. Chapter 3's talisman
represents escape, and it's no coincidence that
this totem is the only one of the three that's
broken upon use. Because, while he leaves New York
behind for a time, ultimately, there is no escape.
It's the first rule the audience learns in
John Wick, and it's the one that gets John in the
most trouble. The Continental is a chain of hotels
operated by the High Table, with locations around
the world catering to globetrotting assassins.
The Continental offers a variety of specialized
services for their clients, such as doctors,
arms dealers, and tailors who will make you the
perfect kevlar-lined suit. But the most important
thing it provides is peace of mind.
Anyone who conducts the business of
assassination on Continental grounds will be
summarily excommunicated by the High Table.
"You know the rules. No business can be conducted
on these premises lest incurring heavy penalties."
Completely cut off from the society's resources,
excommunicated assassins are easy prey for anyone
who wants them dead. Guests are required to leave
all grudges and contracts at the door. That way
they can enjoy a drink and a good night's sleep
without worrying about whether they'll wake up.
John breaks this cardinal rule when he kills
Santino D'Antonio in the New York Continental
bar at the end of Chapter 2. This leads to not
only his own excommunication, but consequences
for anyone who aided the assassination or
his escape from the High Table's judgement.
Winston nearly loses his position and his life for
offering John a one-hour head start from pursuit.
The Continental is sacred, not just as a base, but
as a symbol that allows these cold-blooded killers
to see themselves as civilized.
When one considers the violence and cruelty of the
real world, action movies can become a very guilty
pleasure. Gun violence kills about 100 people in
the United States each day, and it's impossible
to ignore how popular culture normalizes or
even romanticizes killing people with guns.
The John Wick series in particular depicts gun
violence as, well, extremely cool. Throughout
the films' nearly non-stop action sequences,
it's next to impossible not to delight in the
creativity with which John Wick dispatches
his foes. Some tallies put John’s kill count
at nearly 300 over the course of the first three
films. Not all of them are with guns of course.
But there's a particular, subtle creative
choice that helps keep the John Wick audience
from stopping to consider the carnage for even
a moment. Despite the outrageous death toll,
the series so far features absolutely zero
collateral damage. Apart from some mobsters in
over their heads in the first film, who presumably
serve Under the Table, everyone John kills is also
a killer. This effectively makes homicide as
"in bounds" for John as punching is for a boxer.
When you consider the psychic damage of
decades of films in which thousands of
random people die. These poor souls trapped in
crumbling skyscrapers destroyed by monsters,
aliens, and natural disasters. John Wick's
polite isolation of violence is almost
refreshing by comparison.
Part of the reason why the John Wick
franchise can isolate the scope of its
violence specifically to the world of assassins
is that, as far as the films are concerned,
there is nothing but the world of assassins.
In behind the scenes featurettes,
producer/directors Chad Stahelski
and David Leitch speak of the world
of the first film as being "heightened like a
graphic novel." But as the series has evolved,
it's much more apt to say that the world of John
Wick is like a video game. John’s is a world that
may appear to be open and fleshed out, but in
fact centers around only one idea or objective.
In the John Wick films, everything the audience
encounters revolves around professional killing.
The Continental is like a home
base where assassins can return,
recover, and upgrade themselves with new
weapons, health, and armor between stages.
The society has its own economy and its own rules
that "players" honor even when no authority figure
is watching. And since the High Table seems
to freely operate with no threat of police or
government interference, there is no outside
authority to enforce the kind of consequences
one might face for their actions in the real
world. Only the rules of the game matter.
The John Wick series adopts the
trappings of a virtual world, but when it comes to
the actual filmmaking, there's very little virtual
about them. One of the traits that separates the
John Wick films from other hit action franchises
of its time is its relatively spare use of
visual effects in favor of practical stunts.
Chad Stahelski and David Leitch, who co-directed
the first chapter, are the co-founders of 87eleven
Action Design, a collective of stunt
performers and coordinators who have been
working on Hollywood productions for decades.
87eleven’s influence has recently exploded,
thanks in large part to the success of John Wick.
87eleven employs a wealth of stunt and martial
arts expertise and an intricate pre-visualization
process to experiment, design, and rehearse long,
complicated fight scenes. They hold to
an obsessive standard of quality while
also keeping the on-set production times, and
therefore the expense of shooting, under control.
While blockbuster action franchises boast
computer-driven effects shots numbering
in the thousands, the John Wick series is about
showing off the elegance of practical stunt work,
with CGI only taking prominence under specific
circumstances, such as the motorcycle chase in
Chapter 3. That's not to say that there isn't
a great deal of CGI at play in John Wick.
Like most modern movies, there are plenty of
computer-generated gun flares, blood splatters,
hidden cuts and erased wires, but the effects
are supporting the players, not the star.
It's a different variety of spectacle more akin
to martial arts films than other modern American
action spectacles.
The John Wick series' signature of long, close-up
action takes is only possible because Keanu
Reeves is a performer who is willing to dedicate
countless hours to mastering any skill that the
script demands. In preparation for each John Wick
film, Reeves put in months of full-time training
in martial arts, tactical shooting, and precision
driving. As a result, the filmmakers have
rarely had to stage scenes around hiding a stunt
actor. This has also allowed them to maintain
Reeve’s connection with the audience throughout.
Director Chad Stahelski was Reeves' stunt double
for the Matrix films, and the two have a very
close relationship. This means Stahelski is
intimately familiar with Reeves' potential
and limitations, and he playfully exploits
Reeves' habit of gleefully throwing
himself into training for a film.
For Chapter 2, Stahelski brought in Brazilian
masters the Machado brothers to help Keanu perfect
his jiu-jitsu, and sent him to firearms training
with world champion sport shooter Taran Butler.
The results are dazzling and a little terrifying.
It would be a bad idea to pick a fight with Keanu
Reeves. When Reeves suggested that John Wick
ride a horse in Chapter 3, Stahelski assigned
him to learn trick riding because just learning to
ride a horse would be "too easy." Did we mention
that Reeves also plays creative roles behind
the camera, pitching story and stunt ideas?
Still, let's remember to give some love to Reeves'
stunt double Jackson Spidell, who gets tagged in
to take John Wick's nastiest falls.
Keanu Reeves isn't the only John Wick star
who undergoes intensive stunt training.
In fact, it's expected of just about everyone.
Any actor portraying a character who gets actively
involved in action sequences is expected to meet
the rigorous standards of the full-time stunt
performers who make up the armies of nondescript
goons dispatched by John Wick and company.
The goal is to use doubles as rarely as possible,
allowing the camera to move freely and maintain
a connection to the characters throughout
fight sequences. The cast and crew refer
to this practice as "The John Wick Program."
Each actor gets trained in a fighting style
specific to their character, often built
off of the performer's preexisting skills.
Adrianne Palicki, who played Ms. Perkins in the
first film, paired with stunt performer Heidi
Moneymaker. Moneymaker, Scarlet Johannsen's Black
Widow double, helped to develop a judo-based style
that would allow her to convincingly take down
the larger Reeves. Meanwhile Michael Nyqvist,
portraying Viggo, was assigned a "drunken master"
style to portray a tough brawler past his prime
who would have to cheat to win. Common,
playing Cassian in the second film,
threw himself into gun-fu and knife training. Ruby
Rose played the silent but very lethal Ares. She
perfected a style based on her boxing skills.
The grand champion of "The John Wick
Program, " apart from Reeves himself, is
undoubtedly Halle Berry, who played Sofia.
Berry aggressively pursued her role in Chapter
3, and then committed to seven months of not
just fighting and shooting lessons, but also
training with her character's stunt dogs.
"No. You cannot keep my dog."
In the world of John Wick, the last thing you ever
want to do is piss off the Baba Yaga. Not since
Kill Bill's Beatrix Kiddo has American cinema seen
such an unstoppable force of vengeance to roar,
rampage, and get bloody satisfaction. John Wick
is a killing machine of unprecedented versatility.
He’s a living weapon in whose hands anything
from a car, to a pencil, to a library book is
a deadly weapon. John Wick can construct a
functioning pistol out of antique gun parts
in the time it takes you to break down a
door. He is cartoonishly good at violence.
It's difficult to imagine how much further
the John Wick series can take the story and
the character in the promised Chapters Four and
Five, which are expected to complete the series.
The creators have established a set of rules that
have contributed greatly to the films' success.
But as the series draws toward its climax
and audience expectations continue to rise,
Chad Stahelski and company may find adhering
to those rules to be a difficult challenge.
How strict should a film series' style guide
be? Can John Wick expand its scale while
holding its shape across two more chapters?
In order to keep the premise from going stale,
will the creators themselves have to do the
unthinkable, and change the rules of John Wick?
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about John Wick
are coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a single one.